je m'appelle charlie je suis un élève du
collège de saint-andré-les-alpes et il
voudrait savoir qu'est ce que vous
entendez par écologie puisque encore
aujourd'hui 18 usines peuvent déverser
leurs déchets dans la mer des pesticides
polluent nos sols et donc notre
alimentation en europe 20 mille tonnes
de déchets électroniques sont envoyés au
nigeria et les déchets plastiques
envahissent nos océans et notre planète
quand est ce que vous allez réagir
vous en avez le pouvoir et une dernière
question monsieur puisque c'est l'argent
qui nous a amenés à négliger l'écologie
vous pensez qu'on proche d'une nouvelle
planète est de l'argent charlie tu m'a
dit tu vous avez le pouvoir d'en sortir
du jour au lendemain
vous avez le pouvoir sur les pays n'ont
pas totalement ses suites débat pour
toutes les raisons que j'ai évoquées
moi si je dis par exemple demain en
france plus un pesticide
je dois dit en même temps pouvoir dire
la france elle importe plus aucun
produit il ya un pesticide ce qui est
quasiment impossible parce que d'abord
aujourd'hui notre agriculture elle en
utilise y compris dans le bio a beaucoup
de beaucoup de producteurs de bio
utilise encore un peu de pesticides des
choses parce qu'on en a qui sont
nécessaires tous les pesticides ne sont
pas j'arrive un jeu revient toi
t'inquiète pas ne sont pas mauvais pour
la santé y en a qui ont des pratiques
complètent
mais je peux pas du jour au lendemain
dire tout le monde passe d'un modèle à
l'autre c'est impossible je peux pas
être dans le 0 100 est il faut que je
donne une perspective que je laisse des
gens changer progressivement de modèle
je dois les inciter au maximum à aller
le plus vite possible
est ce que je peux aller plus vite dans
la sortie de des émissions de co2 oui et
donc là on a commencé mais fois les plus
forts sur ce sujet est ce qu'il ya des
solutions plus intelligentes moi j'en
suis convaincu elles se construisent
aussi localement mais je peux pas de là
où je suis seul dire c'est zéro au sens
du jour au lendemain parce que
simplement nous mêmes on dépend d'autres
pays parce que on a une vie économique
parce que des tas de familles qui vivent
aussi aujourd'hui de ça il y en a
d'autres qui sont en train de vivre sur
un nouveau modèle qui est en train
d'arriver
et donc c'est pour ça anna par rapport à
ta question que ce qu'on doit faire
c'est une transition une transition
c'est le passage d'un modèle à l'autre
c'est le passage d'un système qui avait
aucune préoccupation écologique dans ses
fondamentaux et qu'ils n'étaient que
économique et sur le profit qu'on doit
faire passer à un modèle qui produit et
qui intègre la totalité de ses effets
sur l'environnement
alors ça le défi qui est le nôtre
aujourd'hui c'est de le faire le plus
vite possible parce que maintenant les
conséquences sont tangibles
on a fait beaucoup de choses que je
défends les ministres vont revenir on
continuera en continu en parler moi je
pense et ce débat là dessus moi mais
claire beaucoup qu'on peut faire plus
vite plus fort plus loin et donc qu'on
peu accéléré cette transition et on peut
le faire si on donne plus de pouvoir aux
acteurs locaux et si on change sans
doute un peu nos méthodes
c'est à dire les solutions ne sont pas
en intégralité ne peuvent pas être
trouvées dans par rapport à ça c'est
très clair que le modèle du tout argent
déterminer est-ce que tu peux dire je
dois choisir l'un contre l'autre
tu dois produire si tu veux produire des
richesses pour ensuite pouvoir les
répartir et faire fonctionner une
société donc il y aura toujours de
l'argent dans une société
mais l'argent une faune il détester ni
l'adoré faut l'utiliser pour ce qu'il
est c'est à dire être un moyen pour
faire des choses ce qui est clair c'est
qu'on doit remettre dans notre modèle
productif un objectif écologique
beaucoup plus fort et elle est beaucoup
plus vite